i want to start today with something
many of you have been writing to me
about and it's the question essentially
if joe biden doesn't run for re-election
do democrats have any good candidates
for 2024 particularly to run against
donald trump if he's the nominee or ron
desantis if he's the nominee now why are
we contextualizing this with trump and
desantis well because they're the only
two pool polling anything even remotely
viable in every cpac straw poll and
republican opinion poll it's trump
leading
and then ron desantis with between 10
and 22
depending on the poll or straw poll that
you look at everybody else is in the low
single digits so at least for now let's
theorize
that it will be or is likely to be
donald trump or ron desantis in 2024.
now i've already said before uh it's
unclear if joe biden is going to run for
reelection the language being used by
the white house is very narrow when gen
saki is asked questions like uh if joe
biden plans to run why hasn't he
announced or or filed or whatever and
she'll say joe biden has the intention
of running for re-election which is a
very specifically worded phrase i think
they just don't know if joe biden's
going to run for re-election or they may
know he's not going to
and then the question becomes well well
so then what and much of this is wrapped
up with how the midterm elections go
much of this connects to
the continued and obvious efforts that
the right is going to make to take the
election whether they win it or not
and unfortunately it's not looking very
good
i think it would be an obvious lie if i
said to you there's a great bullpen
right now there's all sorts of great
people first of all if biden does run
for re-election against trump i don't
see that going well for biden and i've
explained before that one of the reasons
for that is
so far biden's presidency although there
is no doubt that there have been a
number of tangible successes which i i
outlined last week
maybe the week before
it has not been an interesting
presidency in the sense of inspiring
people uh joe biden's approval has been
trickling down and it seems to me that
uh donald trump if than if he was the
nominee against joe biden
would be able to sort of reinvigorate a
lot of the same people uh on whose vote
he won in 2016. i don't see that going
particularly well
um i i am unsure about biden versus
desantis but unfortunately desantis is
almost like a more competent trump which
can be very dangerous so then the
immediate conversation becomes if not
biden what about kamala harris it would
be natural in some sense
that there would sort of be a primary
but really that if it's not biden
the dnc would kind of anoint kamala
harris as the de facto nominee
that seems very problematic uh kamala
harris's current approval or
favorability is 39
and that's lower
than every recent vice president and
some by a lot uh at this point in time
this was taken at day 378.
mike pence was uh more popular and more
liked than kamala harris
uh joe biden was more popular and more
liked than kamala harris as vice
president dick cheney was
significantly more favorable favorably
seen than kamala harris and al gore was
dramatically more favorably seen than
kamala harris so the numbers don't look
great
for kamala harris right now it looks
like a very uphill battle if it's going
to be harris versus trump
or harris versus ronda santa so that
doesn't look good
then there was this idea of bring
hillary clinton back now i already
talked about why i think that's not a
good idea i think it can't possibly go
well
uh and
there are a number of different reasons
one is that hillary clinton never really
inspired um
the the type of energy that i think is
necessary particularly running against a
reinvigorated trumpian electorate and
even if it's desantis it will still be a
trumpian electorate desantis is a sort
of trump although now they are publicly
feuding trump and desantis are the
electorate is quite similar
so then you've got the people saying
well bernie bernie's the guy it's
finally bernie's time
uh i'm not gonna blow smoke anywhere
um to me bernie's time is done
bernie ran twice uh he um would be 83 at
the time of inauguration
if the idea is that there needs to be
more energy than biden although i agree
that bernie has more energy than biden
it's not seeming to me
like the guy who already lost twice
um is going to be the guy who at 83 is
going to come in and you know blow the
top off the electorate and defeat trump
or desantis if you have
evidence and data that suggests it could
be bernie let me know i'm willing to be
told i'm wrong but it's not seeming
great
then you've got the aoc crowd people say
aoc aoc has the energy she has the
likability that's true aoc has a lot of
energy aoc would be old enough to be
president
by two months
uh roughly two and a half months
something like that at the time of the
next inauguration
it's not seeming plausible to me
that 34 year old aoc
successfully runs on the basis that i'll
be old enough by two months on
inauguration day
that doesn't seem to me like the recipe
for a success i'm just being realistic
with you i read something about amy
klobuchar
tons of people hate amy klobuchar she
never pulled more than six in 2020 but i
have to tell you klobuchar to me sounds
less crazy than harris or hillary in the
context of 2024. now perry bacon jr
wrote a piece in the washington post
talking about can among other people
kentucky governor andy beshear
a white male democrat but from the south
and a governor rather than a senator
which sometimes can be more appealing to
people in
different parts of the country the south
the midwest etc it's an interesting idea
i don't know much about andy bashir so
i'll sort of put a pin in that but
that's something perry bacon jr wrote
about now perry bacon jr also writes
about tim kaine who ran alongside
hillary in 2016. it is difficult to
imagine a less exciting
and more milk toast candidate than tim
kaine i i feel almost embarrassed to
even mention the idea of tim kaine as
the nominee
um
it's it's very tough to imagine that's
the direction so i don't see any strong
candidates right now a few things i will
mention on rhetoric and what i mean by
that is
in terms of being able to mix it up with
people effectively in media and in
debates um and come up with sort of like
snappy comebacks and and optics
there's something interesting about pete
but edge edge
but he's already suffered and been the
target of significant character
assassination in his role as secretary
of department of transportation
secretary of transportation you don't
typically see that
secretary of transportation
into presidential candidate it's unclear
what his fate would be so i'm just not
sure about it and then it has to be said
that on policy elizabeth warren is one
of the most left candidates of anybody
who's recently run other than bernie her
wealth tax proposal is something to the
left of what most democratic candidates
have proposed but
on a personality personality level the
country really does not seem to like
elizabeth warren so that doesn't seem
particularly good either so
it's a very tough situation
let's get through the midterms insofar
as what happens will inform what the
dynamics of 2024 might be
but i am not particularly optimistic
about the farm team right now
i'm open to having my mind changed let
me know what you think
even if like me you're not vegan and
you're not vegetarian
eating a more plant-based diet is a
really great thing to do for a number of
different reasons and our sponsor just
egg is the delicious plant-based egg you
can use it anywhere you use traditional
eggs because the taste and texture are
identical but just eggplant-based eggs
have the same amount of protein as
traditional eggs i use it all the time
at home you can make fluffy scrambled
eggs you can make omelettes you can make
quiche frittata crepes
fried rice you should see my fried rice
recipe you can really use it anywhere in
baking or anywhere you would use
traditional eggs when i first tried just
egg
i was surprised
that a plant-based egg could both taste
and cook
just like traditional eggs you can get
it at the grocery store instacart amazon
go try it eating a more plant-based diet
is a great decision i do it and i'm not
vegan or vegetarian and just egg makes
it that much more easy and delicious